gravity
ah
leave
we just wanna come
I'm chopping
this is a sonic Maddy
stop me now
having such a good time
stop
just give me
suck me
my way to my
on a collision
I on the sideline
love
anybody thank you Wow oh my god you guys
are awesome you guys are awesome you
guys were confusing and awesome and my
mom has those boots by the way she wants
them back ladies and gentlemen you know
when you see a dancing crab and a baby
bird with a paper collar that you could
only be at the Ubisoft III press
conference welcome welcome
dancers can you guys bring it up have
you first second just gather around get
behind me here it's a special year and I
want to take a moment to do something
that's going to feel a little
incongruous and potentially even
uncomfortable for some of you there's no
smooth or easy way to do this but we all
felt really strongly when we were
rehearsing today that we needed to say
this so before we start
everyone here Ubisoft want to offer our
deepest sympathies to the people
affected by this weekend's tragedy in
Orlando our hearts the hearts of
everyone in Paris in France in the
United States and around the world are
with you and now
ah and now with a human giraffe on my
right and a candy cane on my left I'm
going to make a very hard right turn and
get into the fun stuff thanks for coming
on guys dance away dance away the